boa noite eu estou um pouco ansioso
então para começar é fazer um negócio
assim eu falar complexas densidade
beleza complexa complexo complexo é isso
que eu gosto agora tô sentindo em casa
tirar um tempo e aí estão cansados então
vou me apresentar né
eu sou bruno peron ontem 19 anos e desde
cedo e gostei muito de arte né e de
fazer arte mesmo assim também
então eu ia para a escola que desde os
13 anos eu ia de bicicleta e eu ia
reparando as coisas da cidade e eu
comecei a reparar muito nas pichações
nos prédios na tudo e eu ficava pensando
em disputar pichando cara que eles estão
fazendo sabe mas eu vi uma forma de
expressão naquilo que eu achava muito
interessante e e eu no meu auge de 13
anos de idade trabalhava na escola e aí
eu ia para a escola via chegar fazer o
quê na aula fazendo caderno né
minha mãe não gostava muito profundo
também não mas era uma forma que eu
gostava de me expressar
aos poucos eu comecei a reparar nos
grafites também teve uma outra forma que
era de pegar um pouco as pichações
transformar em perspectiva ao tentar
passar alguma coisa diferente e falei
bom acho que consigo fazer isso aí
também e comecei a fazer de novo na capa
do caderno
comecei a fazer e fazia chegar em casa
fazia e eu adorava fazer isso era uma
coisa que para mim significa muito
só que aos poucos a partir do grafite eu
me eu me reuni muito movimento hip hop
que é
são quatro elementos é o grafite rap o
de jailbreak ea início do grafite
eu comecei a escutar muito rápido nesse
meio porque as pessoas que andavam
escutavam rep
eu ia para a escola escutaram rep vendo
pra frente as pichações são tudo aquilo
pra mim era o meu
tudo e era um totalmente diferente do
que eu vivia na verdade só que uma
identidade ficava com aquilo que achava
que uma forma muito diferente de se
expressar porque tinha gente falando o
que muita gente está vivendo e tinha
muita gente tentando esconder o que as
pessoas estava vivendo
e aí eu ficar meu o rap é uma forma
muito legal de se expressar também e eu
lembro de uma frase que marcou muito que
foi do facção central que é uma música
que chama juventude de atitude e o
refrão é não se preocupem porque nós
somos assim somos a nova geração e não
somos tão ruins
e eu ali por volta de uns 15 anos
escutando facção central eu fiquei civil
a gente é tão ruim assim o cara tá
falando desse jeito eu não pode ser e e
aí eu escutava muito e eu falei assim
boa vou tentar escrever também né
e ali com os 16 anos comecei a fazer
fazer o inverso na escola tinha alguns
amigos meus também estavam rep a gente
tentar fazer rima mas é horrível era
tipo jarre mas já nela com batatas é
nada a ver mas era legal a gente sentia
bem fazendo aquilo sim só que aos poucos
eu comecei a fazer rima de verdade só
que não tão longo quanto o rep
esse aí pois é poesia também não é legal
vou tentar me expressar de uma outra
forma e comecei a escrever poemas e aí
eu me dediquei totalmente a isso eu por
volta de 2012 ele escrevia todo dia tudo
que eu via eu queria escrever sobre e
tentava fazer isso realmente assim todo
dia toda hora e onde eu tava pra quem
estava do lado isso foi tomando muita
importância na minha vida até 2013
entrei na faculdade de psicologia e eu
disse a meu ver não dá acho que eu
preciso encarar a escrita como algo
profissional eu quero ser escritor
aí sim mas num poucas pessoas
escritores mas eu conheço muitos que
gostam de ler vou montar um sarau isso
em 2014 já só que eu falei mostra galera
vamos lá vai ter um fará o seu key pa
foi uma pessoa aí eu penso que
reclamando do tipo não foi ninguém tal
aí eu pensei cara nunca foi no farol
então você não é coisa de adolescente
acho que vai fazer e aí eu falei 'bom
precisa né cara
e aí teve uma oportunidade o pessoal da
faculdade me chamou lá em campinas que é
um dos caras também faz parte do
movimento hip hop e no inquérito que ele
organiza a parada poética então em
novembro eu fui uns amigos meus me
convidaram pra aí ea gente estava lá e
pb beleza e era um farol no bar e porque
os faróis tiveram que invadir o boteco é
porque biblioteca não era mais lugar de
poesia biblioteca lugar de fazer
silêncio detergente muito bem vista
citando [ __ ] mas eu fui num bar e viu
o povo recitando poesia e eu vi um cara
ônibus ante pegando microfone andano
bêbado e recitando um poema e aquilo me
atingiu foi gente que esse cara tá
falando é muito eu sabia
só que eu não bebo mas eu fiquei gente é
muito legal
e aí sim eu consegui tirar o modelo e
fala assim é isso realmente eu gostaria
que tivesse na minha cidade porque ele
estava acessível para as pessoas eram um
dia comum era uma segunda-feira à noite
sabe que não tem na fazenda noite vamos
lá está no bairro sab poesia é legal eu
falei bom vou levar isso isso essa
primeira foi em novembro
e aí eu falei em bom tom a partir de
janeiro eu vou fazer um sarau indaiatuba
e vai ser mensal e vai ser um espaço
público
vai ser elitizado não vai ser político
mas vai ser politizado
então a gente vai conseguir se expressar
da mesma forma que eu via aqueles caras
lá da pichação de grafite que se uniam
como um grupo social para demonstrar o
que ele estava passando no seu período
social histórico é uma demonstração
artística sempre que você tenta falar
sobre o tempo que você está vivendo
melhor forma de se aproximar do agora e
em janeiro começou esse projeto todo o
último sábado vai ter sarau
não adianta e chuva ou sol faça mas e
assim começou
e aí quando me pergunta como ideia pode
mudar o mundo
o gabriel caboca minha palestra ele
falou como tipo e pra mim você é muito
gratificante sabe eu eu consegui vê se
que para mim foi tão natural porque no
começo quando lucas falou assim meu vai
dar uma palestra no tedx eu gostaria eu
fiquei tipo é o que eu estou fazendo
aí o gabriel me responde hoje tipo que
eu mudei a vida do cara saca porque ele
foi começou a frequentar saraus e tipo
eu fico sem palavras com isso
e eu lembro que isso foi muito inspirado
assim pelas pessoas do rap mesmo e eu
gosto muito um cara
o rodrigo vieira vulgo mc marechal que
tem uma música dele que ele fala você
quer ser o melhor vai ser melhor para a
comunidade e é isso que estou tentando
fazer
então pra finalizar a minha arte e deixa
lá a marte e um poema eu me lembro bem
da noite a multidão sensação estranha
vi a vida em vão e ter aumente uma
trincheira a vida era passageira eu me
passar o ferro o ferro passar um pano eu
vi queimada luciano vi passar dos anos
mas nada passa que senti depois de
passado
já basta o que restou aqui sou novo mas
também sentir que não tenho culpa se não
só desse planeta e perdoe a órbita e
olhe pela luneta a ampulheta também diz
o que cochiche são as estrelas pois o
tempo o tempo vai só volta com revolta
porta certa chave torta e não aborda a
missão que nos provoca a questão dos
sentimentos sensação envolvimento ficção
pois sou da lama ao caos e do causa
lamas o olho do furacão sobre o cão em
chamas sou a favor que trago a cada
trago sozinho sua vida e moinhos o poeta
sem estrada profissão andarilho e cba
quanto o suficiente para alimentar meu
filho chamou ele de sonho e vocês
sobrevivem como
uns